Now, this is how I think about the problem.
Does this phenomenon occur because the process which produces intertweet time is
in fact random, or is it in fact influenced by factors which we have not seen.
If the answer is the former, then the best we can do is our exponential fit
estimator with our guess of 8,585.5 seconds, which we developed above.
However, if it's the latter, then we can reduce the inherent variance,
effectively reducing the spread, making intertweet time more predictable by
finding the factors on which intertweet time depends.
To see this, let's look at a simple example.
But if it's the latter, then we can reduce the inherent variance,
effectively reducing the spread, making intertweet time more predictable by
finding the factors on which intertweet time depends.
Now, to see this, let's look at a simple example.